the church of the broken god worships
the holiness of machinery and the god
meccan who rules over all things what
would you do if society as we know it
crumbled humanity fell from grace and
the church took over the world at large
would you make your way to the cogwork
orthodoxy to upgrade your fragile meat
body with some pristine machinery what
sort of changes would you make how are
you going to adapt to the new world
order we posed this question to the
amazing fans of scp-explained and you
told us all about all the ways you would
upgrade your fragile human bodies to
adjust to the new world so let's get
right to it and see who would rise to
the challenge and please the mighty
meccan and who would perish as a useless
flesh bag shawn michelson said i would
replace my left arm with nerve damage
from when i broke it as a kid and the
bionic replacement would be capable of
morphing into any shape necessary for
the task at hand lockpick axe sword etc
we're off to a great start here shawn
you turning your left arm into the
world's coolest swiss army knife sounds
like a heck of an upgrade now that
you've accepted mccain into your heart
you'll never have to go to the hardware
store again
quick question though what are you
planning on using that lockpick for if
you're planning a heist make sure you do
it safely and see if you can transform
that arm into a sweet getaway car
pyronod 682 said i always took pride in
my size if i got enhancements at all i'd
get some that would either make me a
proper goliath or a tall gaunt but
sturdy frame either way my presence
would be enough to intimidate so
how tall are we talking here slenderman
tall empire state building tall either
way it's admirable that in a world where
you can be any cybernetically enhanced
thing you want you're choosing to just
be big and scary hey if it's good enough
for mechagodzilla it's good enough for
us ivan pikinon said the most fragile
and exposed part of our body are
probably the eyes a prototype might be a
new model of artificial eyes that can
provide an omnidirectional sight being
of metal they don't need to be hydrated
making the person with them having a
constant view of the surroundings it
might also allow blind people to be able
to see again that is an excellent idea
you'll put the eye drop companies out of
business for good not to mention how the
global glasses economy would crash but
that's a small price to pay for giving
supervision to anyone who wants it maybe
you'll even be able to see why kids love
the taste of cinnamon toast crunch
kaiser afini said i would seek the most
advanced upgrade i can think of one that
allowed me to create a research center
inside a black hole allowing the
movement of myself and anything else i
designate to and from it distance and
time are unacceptable hindrances in the
project of optimizing the omniverse
euclidean physics only limit advanced
inventions as well we must evolve past
such limitations well now you're
thinking outside the box outside of all
euclidean shapes really not entirely
sure what kind of upgrade would let you
set up shop inside a black hole but
there's nothing wrong with shooting for
the stars or a gravitational pull strong
enough to absorb the stars and snuff out
their light leaving only darkness behind
joss moore said i would attempt to
integrate
scp-294 into my own body providing
limitless sustenance and a very
effective weapon if used creatively why
upgrade your body so that it no longer
needs food and water when you can just
stick a coffee machine in your chest and
have endless mochaccinos that's a life
of luxury plus scp-294 can produce
non-potable liquids such as sulfuric
acid and even liquid nitrogen for when
you really need someone to chill it's
got everything you need and now it's
part of your body it might be a little
clunky carrying around a vending machine
everywhere but who needs to fit through
doors when you can have all the banana
smoothies you could ever want mason
skorup said the skin would be
interesting i'm imagining a sleek human
form a much more aesthetically awesome
kind of shield flexible and durable much
more resilient body temperature
regulation would be the first issue that
comes to mind no more glands is a pretty
big overhaul as well as the fact that
your skin is where all of your nerve
feelers are located perks no acne body
odor splinters or other damage cool
lights and stuff if you want that sleek
metallic shine potentially way upgraded
physical senses but cons you look like a
robot you'd be pretty conductive i guess
that could also be a perk so
surroundings of extreme temperatures
could pose threats your skin absorbs a
lot of things so that would go away as
well as the microbiome on it that would
make you much more readily sterile but
could also vector diseases that jump
onto your exterior more easily and
another big thing i think of is
tarnishing we don't want an elden ring
scenario on our hands that being said
you would absolutely kill it at any
comic con or drag show you went to we
should all be so lucky as to live in the
future mason has imagined just think of
it throngs of beautiful robot people in
mind to get robo patrick stewart's
autograph at comic-con before watching a
real-life transformer performance and
all the while no one sweats or smells
now that's paradise on earth right there
xavier rauch said i'd personally like to
get my left arm modified for a more
industrial looking one with a similar
look to the clockwork virus sort of
style for my own reasons like being able
to show off my taste in industrial stuff
being able to push and carry things
easier with my non-dominant hand or even
just look more proud of myself that is
what i do if i could get my arm all
mechanized who said style over substance
is a bad thing rock that new clockwork
arm and usher in a new industrial
fashion craze all the coolest mechanized
kids are doing it
muhammar said i always wonder what it
feels like to become a toaster oh boy do
we have an scp for you jurok 404 said
human evolution would probably just be
don't need sleep don't need food can be
quick can learn faster cannot kill
scp-682 because nothing can hey now have
a bit more faith in the fully mechanized
future if we can beat sleep then we can
take on that overgrown lizard maybe
minna arashi said i'd probably go with a
full body prosthesis like in the anime
ghost in the shell with several notable
changes the arms will be transforming
rifles with the option to deploy blades
of either mantis style i.e cyberpunk or
bayonets style as for the legs they
would extend into a form that's similar
to the hind legs like that of a canine
or similar animal i'd also have cloaking
and enhanced hearing and eyesight
allowing me to see objects outside of
the visible spectrum and listen in on
conversations that are taking place in
the next room with this setup i'd say
i'd be something like a soldier or spy
as i imagined the upkeep on a body such
as this would be high and military grade
just imagine someone with mantis blades
and extending legs jumping out at you
from the shadows out of nowhere
screeching in your face i'd say that any
normal person would have to clean
themselves up after witnessing such a
sight you know we've talked about a lot
of terrifying things on this channel but
the idea of walking down the street
after a lovely night out at the robot
pub and suddenly seeing a figure leap
out of the shadows letting out an unholy
screech as it brandishes its mantis
blades and skitters towards you on long
insectoid legs yeah that's going to give
us nightmares for a long time
congratulations on coming up with the
scariest upgrade in the comments section
your prize is the sheer unadulterated
terror of all unlucky enough to cross
your path and keeping my therapist
employed jacob rathbone said definitely
a robotic arm that can split into two
functional arms akin to general grievous
and ears with a voice box that can allow
me to speak and understand all languages
but the problem that could arise is that
my voice box could glitch and get stuck
in a language or accent for a time i
think having one of my eyes replaced
with an artificial eye that can read all
known languages would be helpful too
wait wait hold on you're going to put a
voice box in your ears
assuming you meant ears and a voice box
that are separate this is a pretty
useful upgrade you could travel anywhere
you want without needing to bring a
language dictionary or a translator as
long as you head up the cyber pharmacy
for your regular dose of anti-viral
software you shouldn't have to worry
about getting stuck on any one language
make sure you let people know about your
artificial eye though so they don't
think you're flirting with a wink when
you're just trying to read a street sign
shy griff said quite simply i would
infect myself with scp-217
and then do what an infected d-class did
and use scp-212
i have no idea what the resulting
upgrade will be but i will put any of my
improvements to good use edit i would
run myself through scp-914 on the fine
setting to work out any kinks it takes a
lot of ambition to attempt to diy your
own upgrade and there's definitely a
place for that in this new world we love
the energy but before you wind up
hurting yourself with unpredictable
anomalies that might wind up turning you
into something unrecognizable maybe you
should put the youtube tutorial down
save yourself the agony and head to a
certified professional instead tyler
tracy said what i thought of was some
kind of energy upgrade in our fast world
allowing people's minds and hearts to
run perfectly without sleep would
enhance everyone's lives completely
without side effects sure there is an
occasional reporter too saying this and
that about sleepwalking or coming miles
from where they had hit the hay with no
memory of how it happened but as for me
friends i've never been better since my
upgrade get your upgrade and be your
best self
well this seems completely legit to me
no follow-up questions needed especially
not about the sleepwalking or waking up
in strange places that's all probably
completely fine you heard tyler get your
upgrade today and be your best self just
hope you don't walk over the edge of a
cliff while you're getting your eight
hours in chungo mcchungus said i love
your name by the way i would have
additional mechanical arms attached to
myself so that i can pet so many more
mechanical animals like furbys they are
heralds of our gear gifting god i'm sure
of it maybe have an antenna on my head
that causes screens to produce slight
amounts of static on the picture you
know just for fun so
just to clarify your plans for upgrading
your limited human form in the new age
of machines is getting more armed so you
can pet the wild furbies that will roam
the streets and a pranking antenna
sounds like you've got a great handle on
your priorities chungo michungas knows
what living the good life is all about
seth kushman said probably would include
solar panels or some way to plug into a
power source so that you can recharge
energy while sleeping or something
instead of eating also maybe some sort
of light or flashlight thing and maybe a
machine that converts co2 back into o2
also this is more flesh-based so might
not apply but maybe surgically move my
brain into my chest or something somehow
so that all my vital organs are in one
spot and i have just one major weak
point chest instead of two chest and
neck or head oh boy where to begin with
this one the renewable energy and air
purification are all well and good but
what happens to your neck once you move
your brain into your chest what happens
to your head will you put your face on
your chest or keep your face and head
where they are just with an empty skull
and a breeze blowing in one ear and out
the other won't your neck still be a
weak point because your throat and
esophagus are there and the airway could
still be blocked or damaged i have to
move on to the next response before i
get a headache or as you would say a
chest ache
nightingale said built-in respirator
unless part of this clockwork takeover
involves switching to 100 clean energy
and seeing as you specifically name drop
the sect that has the whole steampunk
thing going on a respirator will be
necessary to avoid dying of some lung
disease from the increase of pollutants
in the air a very thoughtful and kind of
depressing answer why stop there scrap
the lungs altogether and eliminate the
need for breathing at all then it
doesn't matter how rancid the air gets
better get rid of your sense of smell
too if we're being honest young love
said literal finger gun upgrades replace
my arms up to my elbows and where i
reload would be by putting in bullets in
the base of my wrist like putting in
coins in an arcade machine with inner
workings functioning similar to a nine
round mag for a 308 hunting rifle firing
with twice as much force within shot
because my replaced limbs would cycle
back all the carbon and other gases back
into the chamber to make it not only
louder but deadlier with a higher
velocity to hit targets from farther
away finger guns actual
finger guns everyone you meet will be on
edge they'll never know if you're just
being a cool friendly dude or if you're
about to blow their head off they won't
be able to tell until it's too late no
notes this is just plain awesome cheesy
miner said i would wish to become
completely mechanical solely for the
purpose of calling anyone that still has
exposed skin meat bags that is a
perfectly valid reason and we here at
scp explain condone any and all meat bag
bullying once mccain has become ruler of
all laugh at them and they're failing
organic bodies oh you've got flesh still
can't afford metal skin did your mom
give you those internal organs
loser francisco souza said i would have
a special compartment in my wrist that
stores all the methane in my body and
then release the pressurized gas and set
it ablaze it's stupid and that's why
it's perfect this is incredible you have
the chance to change anything about
yourself and you went with weaponized
farts you're right it is perfect and
it's a great way to embarrass your
enemies mid-combat while dealing a ton
of damage hey honey how was the battle
today i don't want to talk about it oh
dear what's that smell i said i don't
want to talk about it that's phenomenal
the shy puppet said a chainsaw for a
hand so that i can quote dispose my
enemies more easily end quote and after
a long day of horrific carnage when you
just want to curl up on the couch and
relax you can chop firewood in a snap
dwemer smith said eliminating
individualities in the brain would cause
everybody to think alike and no one
would disagree or be disloyal well this
is just one commenter who should never
be in charge of a post-apocalyptic
society noted just gonna slowly back
away from this one actress hayport said
i would simply have my mind uploaded to
a computer once it's data it can go
anywhere and can be put into anything my
concern is that once i am no longer in a
human body i would lose all emotion and
drive to do anything because usually
that's governed by our complex meat
sacks but if i had some sort of sliders
i could adjust everything about myself
that i think would be enough but the
actual goal is to experience everything
and when there's no more universe when
i'm in space watching everything implode
give out one remaining chuckle as i put
myself in an infinite dream only to wake
if the universe reignites so i can watch
it this is a pretty grand idea but um
one quick question if there's no more
universe what would happen to the
computer you're stored on it would be
part of the universe correct not trying
to rain on your immortality parade but
the mechanics of this one pun intended
are a bit confusing you'll figure
something out though once you've got
that super powered data brain probably
prophet of the eighth legion said from
the moment i understood the weakness of
my flesh it disgusted me i crave the
strength and certainty of steel i aspire
to the purity of the blessed machine you
can cling to your flesh as if it will
not decay and fail you litany of the
omniscience chosen hey everybody the
life of the party is here thanks for
that prophet of the eighth legion it was
quick to the point and just terrifying
enough to set the tone for the rest of
the day death to the old flesh long live
the machines am i right now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy in
space the shy guy questions and theories
and scp-049 what actually is the
pestilence the plague doctor questions
and theories for more questions and
answers from the scp-explained community